this road and Eisenhower State Park is
covered with curious clumps of
earthworms now this is weird oh my god I
almost puked why did the massive
disgusting pile of worms cross the road
I don't know I really I don't understand
anything about this is this a swarm of
worms
biologists please explain this might
look weird but worms are actually very
social creatures worms do travel
together in the same direction as a herd
you just don't really need to worry as
much about a stampede this kind of
clustering behavior can actually protect
the earthworms they create a kind of
mucus or protective covering to deter
predators like flat worms and there's of
course a lot more of this mucus when
there's a big group of worms but why are
the worms in the middle of the road
right before this video for a few days
there's a horrible torrential rainstorm
this means that the ground is likely to
be quite saturated with water so the
worms may have made their way up to the
surface to avoid getting waterlogged the
best place to go to avoid waterlogged
soil is the place of highest elevation
which in this case just happens to be
the middle of a road now every worm has
the same need so every were means up in
the same place the other reason these
worms may all be in the center of the
highway is that maybe there were lots
more worms all over the highway and then
a bunch of cars went by yuck
worms are weird